uh life we all have uh things that
disappoint us yeah you seem to handle
disappointment well
I've had bigger disappointments in my
life how do you handle much bit much
bigger disappointments like bro
especially at this level
I've had people die who I really care
about
and again
life goes on I reflect over it it comes
in waves it comes in waves but then life
moves on time always just keeps ticking
they don't stop for nobody so I'm just I
think people
expect me to handle it the way they
would yeah so they think I'd be like in
the shadows right now like
sad I'm like yeah and everyone else who
care about me do you know I saw a few
people like message me that'll comment
that yeah I'm like it's fine this is
life like look even if you had like
destroyed me five rounds and then killed
me at the end of Flatline me I still I'd
have down spirits of course I'm human
but it sucks to lose don't get me wrong
I love winning I love winning but I'm
still grateful like people don't
understand I'm so grateful for
everything that if you watch the last
episode of um freestyle been in the
episode three of the fight week we
brought Tojo in this fight week who was
um one of the ogs from New Zealand when
it comes to fighting like martial arts
so he and um Lolo
um were part of the they they formed
Balmoral Liga who trained Eugene Doug
Vining Ray cepho
um I think Mark hunt wouldn't spy them a
few times so he was around the era so
those guys so Tojo was at the house with
us oh he was at the hotel but he came to
the house for the dinner and man roll
the clip you have permission to roll the
clip at this park I want to introduce
Master Tojo he's part of the reason that
we
today when we first started in Balmoral
we wanted an Auckland title it's a
ended up here beside being able to go to
shake hands with the ghosts of medicine
square of all the Champions that have
gone prior to these ones thank you
thank you um there's a beautiful species
in gave and then totally gave a speech
and you see Mike in the background Mike
angle of my boy he's he's a cancer as
well I'm half cancer half Leo so he's
like
and I'm there like
yeah you feel it though
I expressed it so it was just the whole
moment man and even there's a there's
something I posted on the other day
there's a picture so I hold two seconds
with um Dan since 2016. Dan's had five
fights in the UFC albums on live yeah
yeah
you can pass it to Kosh oh wow that's
2016. keep scrolling if you want to see
some cool stuff right you're gonna be
upset
oh that's Kai and Ash yeah no no not ash
oh my God so that's even that Valk is
about to make his debut then Dan's
already had five fights in the UFC I was
two years away from making my debut and
Kai was about to be on The Ultimate
Fighter I believe I'll show these guys
as well so see see like and this is a a
small group of fighters from New Zealand
and Australia
um or the anzacs who haven't really um
we have never had any kind of backing
from the government like other sports
and look where we are yeah like I didn't
really get to go I can't go Time Square
anymore yeah but um my face was all over
Time Square my name I dis on you
all up in lights in Times Square yeah
all up in lights in Madison Square
Garden yeah and it's just like [ __ ] I'm
grateful like what a life that's why I
said that's one of my things I always
say what a life there's a there's a
thing that happens I think sometimes
when you approach disappointment is you
feel love from people that don't always
show it
you know and uh when you're winning
there's tons of love but it it might not
necessarily be the love from someone who
like truly cares and sometimes through
this point you find out how much do you
actually care about someone like I told
you earlier like Duvall texted me this
morning nine o'clock he goes man he goes
why am I really sad that is he lost I
feel that man that really that touches
but when you're dominant right when
you're so dominant like you are you
don't give us an opportunity to feel
what it's like when it doesn't go your
way right and now all of a sudden you
have it so there's like this I wonder if
there's this weird Silver Lining to A
Moment Like This though it's incredibly
disappointing you also get to see how
much people care about you I'll be
honest you watch when Bruce Buffer is
announcing me my lips go [ __ ] them yeah
cause he got booze and I go cheered but
I was just like I don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
him so he's eating my read my lips yeah
because I was to say nah I thought about
that I'm focused on this guy right now
yeah afterwards I can basking and all
that and I'm getting so much love on
people were like oh he won the fans back
I'm like my real fans never left yeah my
real fans never left yeah people really
care about you yeah and I think that you
offer some consistency in people's lives
that don't have consistency right so
like you're somebody it's almost like
what Mayweather was or like what LeBron
was in a lot of ways where you where we
just looked at them we're like oh yeah
every year they get into the finals or
Mayweather's like every time it's gonna
fight my life is inconsistent but I know
when I watch Mayweather I can count on
that guy so I think that they go oh my
God he's gonna win yeah like so I think
that there Drake as well I just saw the
thing where he dropped two Milli that's
light work for Drake but still two
million is two million let me ask you
let me tell you something yeah Danny
Danny his money
thanks buddy yeah they love that you
know they gave me like I think 15 grand
because um some guy at the press
conference was like
are you a locked in with it gambling I
was like I only [ __ ] with steak so they
just dashed me like [ __ ] 15 grand for
that yeah yeah thank you thank you all
I'm trying to say is that people I think
they say they see the way that you're
handling it and I think it helps them
cope with it yeah real talk you talk
about it it made me go oh [ __ ] my boy's
gonna be all right your dad gets hurt
and he's like no we're okay
when a baby falls down
that's exactly what's happening well if
you don't give them that reaction
they're like you letting people know
it's all right and it's fine and then
they take that into their lives and they
go oh [ __ ] I'm gonna have disappointing
things happen and I can handle that [ __ ]
with Grace something I've had worse
things happen in my life yeah I
literally worse things I think people
like I said people if they put
themselves in my shoes they think how
would I handle if I was Izzy because
even sometimes people were like there
was a fight when um might have been
either the Romero fight or something
people were like I got [ __ ] on so much
and people like are you okay I'm like
I'm fine but every time I talk people
like oh are you what you need to
apologize to him because the emotional
roller coaster you put him on every time
you fight son like it's because he cares
bro
this guy this guy is like unbearable to
be around yeah
there's a video of Joe Rogan he's
talking to annik or something and then
Theo's right here and then Schultz is
right in the middle and he's just going
I swear to God I looked at them I was
like I need to get the [ __ ] out of the
room
[Laughter]
it's crazy it's bad it's to the point
now where like if I'm going on stage I
can't watch the fight before it'll [ __ ]
you up when you fought [ __ ] yawn yeah
the fight finished yeah literally 30
seconds before I went on stage and those
Mormons got the worst storms
about the tablets yeah but it is it is
weird how we get so invested because I
know not to the highest Stakes that you
go through but I know what it's like to
have a lot of pressure and have a lot of
people believing in you and and needing
to like come through in a moment like no
edits you can't edit a fight right this
is what you do you're on stage
completely different Stakes I don't want
to compare here too and I hate when
Comics go oh it's just like boxing it's
not like boxing the similarities but I
get what they mean I compare these
strippers yeah that's probably more like
it yeah
but but but I so I understand like the
pressure that comes with it
and I swear to God I think I get more
anxious and nervous for your fights than
I do my own shows I know for you know me
I get more anxious for my teammates
fights yeah my fights yeah yeah I bet
you'd be nervous to see me on stage
yeah okay I'll be nervous if you if you
had a fight if you did like a chart you
should you should not what are you
talking about
that Kyrie who KD okay not Kyrie okay oh
I would beat the Sharks
KD that'd be more difficult obviously
because he's seven feet tall
but if you had a fight if you had a
fight I'll definitely if I was like okay
I was just hoping the person is all
right yes like I've talked about it when
I watched some Camaro and Leon when
Kamara was on his way to Victory I was
like okay he's gonna beat him up this
round or whatever I take him down and
then okay he'll be fine but then when he
got knocked out oh yeah and that Paulie
was right next to me and I was like
no yeah if I happen to Leon same thing
I'd be like no because one of them got
hurt badly